visita vi fosse una mappa benvenuti sori
bastare a grandissima richiesta nuovo
episodio che riceve san valentino questa
volta faranno nuovi scherzi perché il
gioco è un gioco nuovo daily che ieri
stranger non sa che ci chiedete di
giocare ascheri strangers il che sarebbe
il fidanzato di scary teacher francis
infine sono usciti dei nuovi episodi
scherzi di san valentino che da quello
che mi piace di più perché fanno un
sacco ridere se volete che facciamo una
seconda parte in cui giochiamo ascheri
stranger nuovamente lasciato un mi piace
qua sono tutte questo video raggiunge 10
mila mi piace giocheremo noi precari
stranger quindi mettetevi comodi prende
tv corner ma iniziamo con gli scatti
sono freddi
[Musica]
o no meno male non li ha colpiti
ecco nicchie stati il pallone è
arrabbiato ci stiamo preparando per gli
schermi bene dall'introduzione abbiamo
capito che francis e molto cattivo nome
feriti e poi ha bucato il pallone a lady
che tali ma noi non siamo nick ottani
questa volta come in speditezza perché
si può scegliere il maschio la femmina
ribaltiamo un altro ragazzo ho visto
tutta la scena e ha detto che ora
inizieremo con gli scherzi avrebbe
allora si è scritto assicuriamo sì che
il vicino abbia un pin tasti
assicuriamoci che il vicino abbia un
sabato infine fantastico questo giorno
di trovare studino dopo di parole con la
pinna quindi mi ci sarà o uno squalo
vediamo anche tiri teaser che lo guarda
allora scrive viene tutto me la tua
carta di credito devo comprare una cosa
e bradley adesso è al piano di sopra nel
mio portafoglio quindi immagino attento
per noi andiamo che non vi sto per
rubare la carta di credito di francis
tracey sensu costumino con i fiorellini
nero del leader
segue siamo saliti sopra allora anche
qua abbiamo la videocamera in cui
possiamo vedere dove sta andando francis
e anche voi stati attenti e ora lui in
giardino quindi sta attendendo i suoi
vestiti per farli asciugare a casa di
francis è molto molto bella e la casa di
spiriti sarei molto carina che vuoi dire
una stato già trovato qualcosa salieri e
segreto o allora sicuramente questa sì
questa ragazza si credono a trovare lo
possiamo vedere il diario ci sono i
codici odyssey della carta di credito
effettivamente c'è la fianco la cacca di
gray the cloud che bella molto meglio di
quelle scritte a me in questi giochi
piace con il giornale
non ho già trovato subito praticamente
lui interrato vicino
non conosco tutta una casa ancora wow
che cosa gigante al vicino ricaverà un
aborto così non ci trova anzi ecco che
cosa compriamo vediamo mai con la carta
di freddo
aspetta aspetta viene assimilato i
codici allora il primo era male vitale
se li ha scritti slay numerico 54 72
allora proviamo abbiamo solo tre
tentativi allora 62 delle fino a squalo
dobbiamo scegliere che cosa comprare
possiamo comprare a uno squalo on air
fino alla scuola costa 10 mila dollari
il delfino mille dollari beh direi che
la scuola è molto cattivo da comprare
però sono anche curioso di vedere il
delfino perché io adori del fiorino
bellissimi dai problemi con i domini
magari
siamo con la scuola dice di continuare
lo scherzo quindi abbiamo questa polvere
per vecchio l'accusa volata quindi
riempiamo la piscina di farne parte
li possiamo uscire archiviazione di
prezzi che rifugge lui è fuori o dentro
si è fuori è fuori interrato ha
presentato in peace piero impossibile
forse perché non abbiamo fatto in tempo
se perché dovevamo prendere dallo squalo
riproviamo i titoli più che va avanti
eccoci qua abbiamo rifatto il livello da
capo così ora prendiamo l'attuale
vediamo se riesce lo scherzo ok credenza
che la divertente vedere loro preferiti
italia che parliamo vediamo la strada ok
lo squalo questo che questa volta
dobbiamo sbrigarci andare velocemente
prima che se ne accorgano
devo andare a vedere dove si usciva da
qui si può uscire ha fatto che possiamo
ascoltare il 29 di sembra stanca delle
scale sono più bravo o che ha fatto
prendere scaricato o disastro disastro
vediamo se dire sì uno scherzo anche
senza le bolle e critici essere
sfornando nomino perché scarica salvato
magari non esca mettiamo le bolle non
riesce a salvarlo rimaniamo tipo di
partita perfetta per i ragazzi si stiamo
abbiamo rifatto sotto lo scherzo questa
volta dobbiamo sbrigare dobbiamo essere
iper super delusi se usciamo subito
e allora se perdiamo questo media siamo
fatti male però ribery che lui non c'è
dobbiamo mostra così è stato
difficilissimo già preso tantissime
volte sono stata la cavano con scarpe
sono riusciti a un mezzo le bolle di
sapone la sua inseparabile borse
lasciate il dipinto che tiri di terra o
freddi squadrando per lo scoperto
qualcos'altro nel frattempo un passaggio
segreto e come dio e portate l'ascoli
uniamo messo li fate si è buttato ecco
lo squalo prossimo scherzi il giorno di
valentini di san valentino
assicuriamoci che il vicino cioè che
ristringere non riesca ad impressionare
spiriti share con destro capacità del
golf c'è sicuramente l'europa di uno
scherzo
che ne dice penso sempre di essere
bellissimo
ok quindi abbiamo capito che francis
facciamoli facendole credere che è un
bravissimo golfista svilire tipo di
scherza di pareva scritto che dobbiamo
manomettere l'attrezzatura da golf di
francis
attenzione però perché lui è qui in
giardino ma già cercando mitissimo
fallito perché il caso tra gatti alza
tempo su come berlino riconosce la
parola gatto sta guardando fuori dalla
finestra cercando il gatto
ok go vinciamo perché abbiamo fallito
subito perché mica sono un po arrabbiato
va bene stiamo girando nella casa
immensa di frates enorme
stiamo cercando qualcosa appunto per
distruggerli
l'attrezzatura da gol per far questo
scherzetto
so che questo gioco è molto più
difficile scritti sé perché i feriti si
attivi sia almeno che cosa di riservare
sono dove potevi fare quale bisogna
scoprirlo da soli ci posso prendere note
bilotta
scopo di rilanciare la stiamo in cucina
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa qua una
torta una banana è la del nostro forse
lo possiamo dar vita a cristo a questo
oggetto in modo saggio guarda certo
perché parlato meglio così che dobbiamo
distrarre il gatto allora che non si di
rabbia attenzione lui ei tumori quasi
giardino scacciamo piano bencini e poco
tv è stata parli perché meluzzi ha detto
che conta fino a 10 quindi sbrighiamoci
attento che non ti grafica meno
distratto e ora che dobbiamo fare però
c'è qualcosa pa nella camera da letto se
sono sonniferi perché c'è l'immagine
delle pillole con scritto zz ea chi fu
dovremo dare i soldi per i apprezzi lo
script izzare cose la colla la foto
gatto abbiamo solo trento secondo sta
per scadere il tempo lo vedete la
soprano barra un accordo fra lui e
dentro casa quindi rimandare a chiamo la
corta ok poi mettiamo la colla a caldo
non ho capito pure troppo
l'importante che funzioni di questo
troppo non ti conviene allontanato
[Musica]
se n'è accorto e ci ha preso l'idea di
approntare ok ragazzi questa è tipo
l'arma non potete capire altre volte
abbiamo sbagliato era finalmente abbiamo
capito cosa dobbiamo fare
non bisogna prendere la porta ma bisogna
tagliare lo spago si chiama si chiama da
una canna da pesca perché così è
trasparente e francis non se ne accorge
finalmente due fortissimi l'alfa io
avevo capito anche se voi non vedrete
tutti gli sbagli vedere il futuro le
parti più divertenti però è davvero
molto più difficile di scary teaser però
non vedo l'ora di vedere una reazione di
francis da questo scherzo allora abbiamo
preso queste tagliare la lenza eccola
qua ok quindi mi raccomando non prendete
la corda normale prendete queste date
certe fuori giardino attenzione non
possiamo perdere di nuovo
e poi abbiamo pochissimo tempo anche
perché fa anche estendendo il tempo che
stiamo andando subito a che fare la
trappola sosteniamo che non arrivi
subito france allora abbiamo preso dalla
legge stimiamo un bello scherzo onesti
che non merita proprio ok dedico e
vedete che ho fatto e trasparente
e allora chi da vedere non manca la
bolla io ti ho riso della domanda
no no no lui ancora dentro casa quello
che abbiamo ancora abbiamo messo tanti
reati quasi che il mattino abbiamo fatto
perché gli svizzeri elettrici
poi è stata la nostra parte preferita
per me la mia parte preferita è stata
quando gli strangers resiste esteri
teacher facevano titanic mangiarlo per
me quella del gatto e il gatto che gioca
a golf
altrimenti se nei commenti la vostra
parte preferita di questi due schermi
che proviamo scherzi scrivete nei
commenti e lascia di un bel b se non
avete visto lo scorso gameplay
concretizzerà in cui sia una proposta di
matrimonio andati a vederlo